lassen Sie uns jetzt den Blick richten
auf die Veranstaltung heute wie gesagt
die Ankündigung ab 14 Uhr werden Sahra
Wagenknecht und alles schwarzer sprechen
Aufstand für Frieden heißt die
Veranstaltung und Basis des Ganzen ist
ein sogenanntes Manifest für den Frieden
das haben schwarzer und Wagen nicht
gemeinsam geschrieben schon 625
000 Menschen haben das unterschrieben
ich darf da mal einen kurzen Satz daraus
zitieren wörtlich wir fordern den
Bundeskanzler auf die Eskalation der
Waffenlieferungen zu stoppen jetzt er
sollte sich auf deutscher wie
europäischer Ebene an die Spitze einer
starken Allianz für einen
Waffenstillstand und
Friedensverhandlungen setzen jetzt denn
jeder verlorene Tag kostet bis zu 1000
weitere Menschen leben und bringt uns
einen dritten Weltkrieg näher
wie schätzen Sie diese zentrale
Botschaft dieses Manifests ein das wäre
schön wenn uns jemand auf russischer
Seite zuhören würde aber Putin hat auch
noch mal in den letzten Tagen auch in
der Rede vor dem Föderationsrat auch vor
drei Tagen bei dieser
Propaganda-Veranstaltung in diesem
Stadion noch mal die russischen
Kriegsziele klar formuliert es geht um
die Wiederherstellung der historischen
russischen Grenzen wobei niemand genau
weiß wo die entsprechend entsprechend
verlaufen also nicht mal in den die
Grenzen der UdSSR reichen dafür im
übrigen auch wir haben gerade gehabt
einer der engsten Alliierten militärisch
sehr wichtig der Tschetschenien Führer
der sprach sogar kürzlich davon dass man
auch Ostdeutschland wieder Heim holen
müssen schließlich gäbe es gerade in
Ostdeutschland doch sehr viele pro
russische Positionen ja und das zeigt so
ein bisschen dass eine
Kompromissfähigkeit auf der russischen
Seite nicht existiert nochmals Putin hat
in mehreren reden immer wieder
klargestellt er erwarte einen langen
Konfl aber am Ende wird den Russland
sozusagen gewinnen weil der Westen die
Demokratien ihn nicht durchstehen werden
und genau darauf spekuliert er und
erkennt natürlich Deutschland sehr gut
und er kann sich gerade in dieser
Polarisierung der Debatte die natürlich
innenpolitisch aus unserer Sicht
natürlich völlig verständlich ist aber
gerade diese Polarisierung der Debatte
ermutigt ihn ja in dieser Sichtweise
weil er sagt die Gegensätze in den
demokratischen Gesellschaften zur
Unterstützung der Ukraine werden
schwächer bzw die Gegensätze werden
größer
wir sollten die Debatte über Frieden und
Friedensverhandlungen nicht führen nein
wir müssen Sie für wir müssen auch immer
wieder ausloten das wird ja auch gemacht
macron oder auch gerade der
Bundeskanzler haben ja auch immer wieder
mit Herrn Putin telefoniert und immer
wieder versucht auch auszuloten ob es
denn vielleicht aktuell dann doch ein
Umdenken gibt eine
Kompromissbereitschaft gibt dass man
sich auf friedensverhandlung einlässt
dem ist leider entsprechend nicht so wie
gesagt ich kann den Wunsch der
Demonstranten völlig nachvollziehen aber
die Frage ist und das müssen sich auch
die Demonstranten eben von vornherein
fragen wie denn ihre friedensappelle auf
russischer Seite gegenüber dem
russischen Präsidenten wirken wirken die
sozusagen deeskalieren dass er sozusagen
darin erkennt das auch er sich bewegen
muss um Friedensverhandlungen zu führen
oder fühlt er sich in seiner Sicht in
seiner Weltsicht bestätigt dass die
Demokratie in schwach sind die
Polarisierung zunimmt und damit die
Unterstützung mit der Ukraine abnimmt
und am Ende wird er gewinnen man kann
das jetzt aus diesem ihren Blickwinkel
als Moment oder Aspekte schwächte
betrachten trotzdem ist denn die Angst
vor einem Dritten Weltkrieg einem
Atomkrieg so unbegründet nein natürlich
wissen wir nicht ich habe wenn sie
selber mit der russischen Militär
Strategie arbeiten dann würden sie
zunächst mal sagen wir sind weiter davon
entfernt dass ein russischer Präsident
dieser Atomwaffen einsetzt und auch
selbst China hat ja damit eine rote
Linie gezogen das war im September
letzten Jahr schon vor dem Besuch des
deutschen Bundeskanzlers auf der
Konferenz der shanghai-organisation wo
Russen und Chinesen zusammenkommen
bereits der Fall das ist bestätigt
worden bei den Besuch des Bundeskanzler
das ist auch selbst für China eine rote
Linie ja ähm also davon sind wir glaube
ich wirklich aktuell weit entfernt aber
Russland hat immer diese nukleare Karte
gespielt gerade in dem Bewusstsein
gerade auch gegenüber Deutschland weil
nichts so sehr wirkt wie eine nukleare
Eskalation sie haben angesprochen ich
kann mich noch sehr gut daran erinnern
in den 80er Jahren hatten eine Million
Menschen auf die Straße die damals gegen
die NATO doppelbeschluss demonstriert
haben am Ende hat Kohl daran
festgehalten und wir wissen heute aus
den Archiven die geöffnet worden sind
auch aus den Memoiren von anderen dass
dieses Festhalten ja mit dieser
Gegenrichtung wenn man so will ein ganz
entscheidender Punkt war der zu dem
Umdenken bei Gorbatschow von Nazis
seiner Zeit geführt haben weil sie
selber dann gesagt dann ähm wir kommen
hier nur in eine Aufrüstung Spirale
hinein und hätte der Westen damals
kleinen beigegeben dann hätten die
Hardliner Position glaube ich damals
auch gewonnen